today we're talking about how steam deck
is coming to new regions of the world
and how the next switch is still a ways
away
following the announcement of valve's
increase to steam deck production
capabilities the handheld pc will now
also be coming to japan's south korea
hong kong and taiwan however these new
reservations will not impact existing
north america united kingdom or europe
reservation timelines so if you're in q3
or q4 like me you'll still be in those q
groups with the same estimated delivery
dates even though it would be really
cool for valve to bump me up to q3 when
it comes to the new markets valve will
partner with komodo for distribution and
you can expect to see steam deck at bid
summit in kyoto and september's tokyo
game show in other steam deck news the
latest update for the device version 3.3
warns users about excessive heat and
cold affecting the unit which can impact
performance officially valve has warned
steam deck owners that the optimal
temperature for the unit is between 0 to
35 degrees celsius or 32 to 95 degrees
fahrenheit going beyond those numbers
we'll see performance throttle as the
internal amd apu chip runs hot to begin
with that cpu will begin to throttle
itself when it reaches 100 degrees
celsius or 212 degrees fahrenheit and
it'll switch off at 105 degrees celsius
or 221 degrees fahrenheit ambient
temperature plays a large role in
determining the internal heat of the
steam deck and you'll want to be in a
moderately cool room when you use the
device unless you're like me and you
don't have it yet then you can be in any
temperature room you want on the
opposite side of the temperature
spectrum cold weather will have an
impact on the battery steam deck
designer lawrence yang told pc gamer
quote just like any battery powered
device the steam dex battery can't
sustain peak power draw at temperatures
below zero degrees celsius or 35 degrees
fahrenheit similar to the way cars have
a tougher time starting in freezing
weather and since we're on the subject
of handhelds with big screens let's talk
about the switch according to a new
report nintendo will likely not be
announcing any new hardware or the long
rumored switch pro this year nintendo is
reportedly currently focusing entirely
on building switch consoles with the
component parts that it has been able to
secure and is aiming to ship 21 million
switch units during the fiscal year that
ends in march 2023 the company still
views the switch as only in the middle
of its life cycle and has diversified
the hardware with the smaller switch
light model that focuses on pure
handheld gaming and the switch oled
which provides a sharper mobile
experience and other quality of life
updates due in part to the ongoing
semiconductor shortage switch sales
declined this year by 22.9
compared to the previous fiscal year
however the system has still been a
success product for nintendo and
lifetime sales currently sit at
101.08 million units gotta be real with
you guys i've been thinking about
getting an oled switch i already have a
switch and i already have a steam deck
on reserve but i've been looking at the
oled and finally thinking maybe maybe
it's time but let me know in the
comments what i should do should i just
wait you know
i don't play the switch that often so
you